the key together a converse out of a
property or a theorem is to understand
that everyone property every theorem has
a um has a premise and therefore a
conclusion that you draw off of that
premise okay the converse is all about
switching those rights switching them so
what's the premise what do we start with
one Madrid ously and the answer is the
premise is parallel lives you start with
those guys right once you start with
them the premise of you then conclude is
our when you draw the print treads
vessels they do this funny thing where
the ratios are always the same okay
that's the conclusion right it wrong
color it it has equal ratios that's
that's the kid okay so here comes my
commerce or right way if the ratio is
that we're talking about if the ratios
of intercepts on trans vessels you could
say are preserved but you might as well
at least in this phrase might as well
just say are equal okay if that is true
then lines are parallel right those
lines other ones either yeah yeah you
were kind of missing this phrase which
has some importance in this in this
converter okay now your phrase was kind
of like if cat then dog window you know
it was kind of a it was fine a holic
line up it was a fake can you cut that
out
there's kind of a sentence like it's
okay now question question property it's
true by the way like we don't just have
to know like we looked at it
experimentally we looked at it
scientifically there's no problem with
that but as mathematicians you have
better and I say better in that they are
more certain you have better tools to
prove that this is true i'll let you
have a thing for us are not going to
force you to but it is not that hard to
prove what you're trying to say here
right i'll give you a big clue where in
recent times have you thought about
those guys don't say anything just you
think about it okay like what direction
would does that lean with okay now my
question at the money is is this true is
this true okay now now the problem is it
is not it is not and with your ruler at
hand I'm going to really quickly draw
you some transversals where the
intercepts are quite clearly in equal
ratio okay but there's lines that ain't
parallel okay you ready it's really easy
you control this remember we started
with like a transversal okay we divided
it up and I I chose to divide up so that
you would get a nice neat ratio off the
back okay so if I just divide this up
really really obviously so that it's
equal ok now I'm going to go like this
oh I'm just yeah are these lines
parallel depends if I say it's a scale
or not okay um now here comes my second
transversal right okay now you can go
ahead and really not that difficult to
find such a point that those intercepts
over here are exactly twice as long as
intercepts over here right what ratio
are they Ian 121 obviously also 121 ok I
have intercepts on these transversals
that are in the same ratio but those
lines are not parallel ok so here the
property works but it's converse it's
busted you know I'm Mythbusters they're
like no I've just proved it dis proving
things but if you want to prove
something the easiest ways to set about
to disprove it and if you can find a
counterexample you only need to find one
counterexample it's out ok it's really
quite simple to do like I said this is
the most common example all the place
where the property does not imply its
converse which is why I picked out this
example um it's also really worth
looking at because this slide is worth
here intercepts and its particular
meaning as on an interval that's been
sliced off by other lines it's really
really important you will see it for
example um ok so I've drawn a circle
right one of those lions that join parts
different parts that goes where they
thought start to see these are chords if
they went on forever we would call them
sequence now what you got here is one
two three four little intervals that
have been cut off by the circumference
of by this point of intersection ok a b
c d
now really really curious thing will
happen you can actually go ahead and do
this drawer a good circle put some
chords on it any way you like so long as
they intercept and what you will find is
this huh now now this is all about this
is a statement completely about
intercepts the intercepts of
intersecting chords in a circle right
and so even though you're like I'm just
thinking of this as a point thinking of
it as an interval is not a on it's not a
backwater use of the word it's actually
quite common we've just been used out of
context okay so you need to get used to
see that word and thinking of thinking
of these or thinking of these they are
also intercepts yeah ah so these guys
parallel but this theorem is there to be
saying about something about these lines
all right the lines that create the
intercepts one two three right so those
are the lines which I am purporting are
parallel that's at least what this
actual property which is true is talking
about talking about the ones that
creates the intercepts which are
comparing yes so this is the this is the
special case that disproves it if you
put up a whole bunch of other ones you
will get different ratios right but for
this one the records are the same which
is what we're trying to show here